in kenya debate is rife over the
morality of hiding wealth in tax havens
that's because the country's president
uhuru kenyatta was among the world's
rich who were named this week in the
pandora papers that's a project that
exposed the people behind these secret
assets president kenyatta and his family
were revealed to have owned an
undeclared network of offshore companies
the news has not been well received
onshore in kenya and in the current
harsh economic times
many kenyans were not too surprised to
learn that their president had stashed
large sums of money abroad the kenyatta
family is known to be among the richest
in the country nevertheless the latest
revelation has caused consternation
most usually are unemployed so i think
the money could have been used to
generate income for the youth for us we
are down and we need money
we need to generate our facilities in
kenyans they are down no one will arrest
him no one will question him they run
the game
it's like an emperor
the documents show the kenyatta family
has been secretly accumulating a fortune
on offshore accounts and in foundations
with assets worth more than 30 million
dollars one of the assets is an
apartment in london
one foundation names mr kenyetta's
mother mama angina as the first
beneficiary and the kenyan president as
the second who would inherit after her
death
the kenyan constitution prohibits a
state officer to hold offshore bank
accounts but there's an exception
so if a state officer
with reasonable
facts
wants to operate a foreign bank account
they can only do so with the express
permission
of the ethics and anti-corruption
commission
it's unknown whether the president had
declared his assets abroad or not but
even if he did not break the law his
reputation is on the line observers say
for years he's been portraying himself
as an advocate of transparency an image
that is now tarnished
the president
is leading a country which
you know attaches itself to national
values and principles of governance
around equality around transparency
around accountability and so if the the
person the the office holder of the
office of the president does not serve
as a good example then it throws the
whole fabric moral and social fabric
into this array
by using offshore accounts the
president's family avoided paying taxes
money that could have been used to
improve public services for kenyans says
member of parliament didmos barasa
another time where the country is also
struggling to bring in enough covenant
in the vaccines to be able to works in
kenyans and also
a skyrocketing cost of living i think is
a serious indictment to him as a person
and
even to his government he should also
apologize to the country if not
resigning
in a country where politicians have a
history of using their political
positions to enrich themselves he thinks
the kenyattas should be held accountable
when they would come they would explain
to the kenyans that the thousands of the
kenyan people who have suffered for lack
of medical
made proper medical equipment the
hospitals there are thousands of kenyans
who have lost their employment because
of a poor environment of doing business
there are thousands of kenyans who are
now grappling with with the effects of
covert 19 their tears would cry revenge
against these people
with less than 10 months until he leaves
office observers say even if the
president did not act illegally it's
still immoral and he has failed to live
up to his own promise to be transparent
with the kenyan people